record and we are on. So hello, hello. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. It's our Zoom call for the 13th of June.
I think that's the 13th of June. Wednesday and it's just a beautiful day here in Minnesota. Today
we're going to talk about several things, mainly on IGF1. IGF1 is insulin growth factor 1. It is
one of the growth factors or growth stimulators in our body that helps us heal. So let's jump right
into this because I talk about IGF1 a lot but I've never really defined it what it is. IGF1 is
produced through growth hormone from the pituitary gland. Pituitary gland, it goes into the liver,
it's converted to IGF1 and it's body IGF products. But IGF1 is the majority that is studied.
It helps with development of growth and of bone. It helps with bone protection.
Development of growth and protection of the brain and of the heart. It can be anti-inflammatory.
It is a vasodilator so it can be beneficial for people who have high blood pressure.
And one thought is this is with a lower IGF1 as we age which typically is true with everyone.
Our IGF1 levels decrease as we age. That does one piece of the blood pressure issue and information
about Alzheimer's connected to that too but it's with high IGF1s. IGF1 is essential for thymus
development and function making of your red blood cells, immune cell function, your kidney function
and development making follicles in the ovary and testicular function. So it has some great functions.
Now there is a lot of use with IGF1. Let's see if I put this on the other slide.
With cellular regeneration and repair so people that have severe autoimmune diseases,
they're starting to use in some circles growth hormones and IGF1 to raise those levels because
a kid increased muscle bone and tissue growth. It's used in the anti-aging market.
Stimulation with growth hormone and IGF1 to make a person feel more youthful.
Feel more energetic. Take away some aches and pains. So you start thinking, wow, this is a really
great thing. Why don't we try to do things that increase IGF1 levels? Well, if you have cancer or
even a smigit of cancer, it increases the growth of cancer cells. So IGF1 is something that we want
to lower when a person is diagnosed with cancer even if it's in a smoldering phase in a
phase where your IVG is down to six, you want to keep IGF1 levels lower.
So this is just pulled from a study here. I indexed it here talking about IGF1 levels here and it's
risked with cancer. It's really with there's probably a thousand studies out there on IGF1 and cancer
that also basically say the same thing. Increased in IGF1 levels are going to increase
cancer growth. Also, there's new studies that increase IGF1 levels with Alzheimer's.
So IGF1 levels will rise when we eat more food. So when humans are consuming more calories
than necessary, it will rise in IGF1 levels. So that is a huge issue and a huge
concern with with with all with mortality issues. So even though it's kind of an economy,
even though IGF1 and growth hormone is used in the anti-aging industry, some doctors that are doing
anti-aging and using growth hormones and such because it can make a person feel better, but it actually
decreases your life expectancy. So IGF1 has been showed over and over to decrease the life expectancy
of all all animals. So and it's not just because of cancer. So it does increase Alzheimer's risk.
It increases degeneration ultimately of the brain. So having high IGF1 levels have a purpose in life
in that it helps you heal after an injury and it helps a child grow. So children have much higher
IGF1 levels because that's part of your growth factor system. They're growing an inch a year
whatever their whatever state that they're in. But as adults, we're not growing anymore. And if we're
continuing to over consume nutrients and foods that is going to stimulate IGF1 function or if we're
taking exogenous IGF1 stimulators to try to feel youth more youthful, we will feel more youthful,
but we will age more rapidly. There's numerous, numerous studies coming out now and I've shared
multiple of these with you at different talks that I've given on fast eat, mimicky diet,
intermittent fasting, and time restricted fasting, whatever we want to call the intermittent,
time restricted are really the same thing. But the FMD is essential for cancer and we're going to talk
about that. So nutrient excess. So when we're consuming too many calories and we're starting to gain
a little bit of weight around our tummy. The problem is we're rising insulin levels and IGF1 levels
and that's that's stimulating more growth, more laid out of fat tissue. And if we have cancer already,
it's going to be increased growth of the cancer. It's going to be an op-regulation of the
m-tore signaling and we talked about the m-tore pathway multiple times. IGF1 is just one of those
stimulators is going to up-regulate or increase the m-tore pathway which is going to increase growth.
All this is the growth pathway. How your body will take in new nutrients, make more cells,
increase growth of cells. So if we have cancer, we do not want to up-regulate m-tore, we do not
want to up-regulate IGF1. Access nutrients decreases the NAD-NADH ratio. This is a very important
ratio that are going to actually do a presentation on quite soon because there's a lot of talk about
using NAD-NADH supplements and it's all about this ratio that we want to maintain. It blocks the
amp pathway which also leads to cancer. So all these red things, if you've got excess nutrients,
lead to increase aging at a high cancer risk and if we already have cancer, increase cancer growth.
Calorie restriction blocks IGF1 signaling, blocks m-tore signaling, helps balance the NAD-NADH
ratio and it increases amp pathways, which this is an anti-cancer, anti-growth pathway.
So that increases longevity of life and it increases a low cancer risk. Here's another picture showing
the same thing. What FMD does, that's the Fasted Mimicking Diet, does two normal cells
and tumor cells on starvation. So it really, this is what we really want to look at for tumor cells.
On tumor cells it's going to increase cell death, it's going to decrease growth because it blocks
these pathways. So super important, the FMD intermittent fasting, making sure we're not consuming too
any calories. Now this of course gets thrown out the window if we're in a caquexic state with rapid
weight loss, it can't seem to keep, to hold our weight. So that's what we have to switch gears a little
bit. Again, this pathway is what we're looking at. We've talked about this in multiple talks,
so I won't spend any more time on that. The next question that came in was, what about Riximson oil?
Can we use Riximson oil? Who's used Riximson oil? And where do we get Riximson oil?
So remember, we talked about with marijuana. So let's kind of go over this a little bit.
Barijuana has, there's three uses of marijuana. There's smokey marijuana. So what do I want to
smoke? Barijuana. So smokey marijuana can help with, can that help kill cancer? No, smokey marijuana is
not going to help kill cancer. Matter of fact, I'm not a fan of recreational smoking a marijuana
because of what it does to the brain. Yes, it does have negative effects on the brain in long-term
studies. We used to do a lot of neurofeedback testing and doing brain scans, and you could tell
if this person was on marijuana or not. And we caught some kids that you're smoking marijuana. No,
yes, you are. I can see it right here. Okay, they passed up. So, but what does smokey marijuana do?
Well, many times people in later stage cancer have pain, right? Well, smokey marijuana could help
take care of pain. And it has none of the side effects of opiates or other drugs. Smokey marijuana,
what else could it do? Well, lots of times people with later stage cancer have difficulty sleeping.
Smokey marijuana could help increase sleep. It can help you sleep better. Could you give
you a better night's sleep? And if you're not getting sleep, then you're not going to heal.
Helping marijuana could smokey marijuana could help decrease nausea. Well, that could be a problem
with, you know, cancer. So, boy, if I could help take care of my nausea, that I could eat better. And
they wouldn't be in such rapid weight loss. Well, smokey marijuana could increase appetite. Well,
that's part of my problem. I don't have any appetite. It'll feel good. I got nausea. I'm exhausted.
I can't sleep. I sleep as horrible and my pain is wrapped up. Well, smokey marijuana could help
with that. So, there's a lot of things that smokey marijuana could do. Now, personally, I have not
ever smoked marijuana, but some of our patients that have gone to this route, very reluctantly,
some of them, have been helped tremendously. So, remember that it is simply an herb that grows naturally.
So, just like anything else, there's some poisonous things that grow naturally, too. Does that mean
we're supposed to do so? No, we have to look at the benefits of it and use it wisely. The second
form of marijuana is CBD oil. Now, CBD oil is the type of oil that is typically
that used for people with seizures, extremely beneficial for seizures. And CBD oil can be
in a form just like this, though. This is an example of Rick Simpson oil or THC oil, but it can be
in a form of this, too. The one CBD high-potency CBD oil we have is in a paste like this as well.
So, CBD is an amylegram dosage. And I've had patients, I just spoke to somebody this morning that
just started using CBD. The patient is extremely about to pay it on a lot of opioids. And you said
they tried CBD. It hasn't really helped, but they only tried it once, but then I asked about the
milligram dosage. It surely took about 12 milligrams, so that's not going to do it. So, you have to
get the milligram dosage up to a high enough point that's going to help take away the pain.
CBD can help with pain. There's more and more studies about CBD and cancer itself.
So, some cancers respond extremely well to just CBD, though. CBD is the done psychoactive form
of the marijuana. You won't get any side effects of feeling weird and things with CBD.
Even in high doses, the CBD is extremely well tolerated.
The dose that we have that comes in for that looks a little bit different like this, but it is in
a paste type form that we have is 120 milligrams a day dosage of CBD. That's a very high dose.
But typically, a person would take anywhere between 25 milligrams a day to 150 milligrams a day
or even 300 milligrams a day of CBD, depending on what you're trying to do.
And then the THC oil is the rick Simpson's oil. That's called rick Simpson's oil after rick Simpson,
who really kind of put it out there and you see that how you smash the bulb, you boil it down,
you dissolve it, you dissolve it, you boil it down, and then you get it down to a paste that is like a
thick molasses as what it is. And you take it on a basis of there's multiple different dosage
charts that I'll show you in just a second of different ways to take the rick Simpson oil.
Have we had many patients have success with rick Simpson oil? Yes. Do I think rick Simpson oil
is great? Yes, but I don't think it's any greater than any other kids are killer that we've tested
people on and use. Just with legality reasons, I can't have this in my office to test. This is
not legal in every state. This is only legal in states that allow typical recreational use of
marijuana. And there are many states that you could get a card for cannabinoid use that is done
by the state. It's done typically through a pharmacy through the state that the state appointed.
And I don't know that it's in a, it depends on the state, but it's usually in a capsule form and
out of this. And I don't know the potency of it in it varies from state to state and pharmacy to
pharmacy. I'm sure. How long does a person typically take this person typically takes this for 90 days
and that is retested? Their rick Simpson's original formula is a 90 day formula, but he does suggest that
you might have to do it multiple times. So it is something that you want to look at. Here's an example
of the cannabis oil treatment starting with three doses daily about half the size of greater rice.
Believe me, I've had people that can only start with one dose of a half a size of greater rice
because this will make you feel loopy. Whereas the CBD oil doesn't really have any side effects,
the THC oil has quote unquote side effects. It doesn't necessarily give you the high
feeling that smoking marijuana gives you. It gets you right to the feeling really groggy stage.
At least this is the experience that I've heard from multiple, multiple patients. So
dosing it, but this is rick Simpson's dosage. They're getting up to three doses daily of a half a
greater rice and a full greater rice, and then you're up to getting a gram a day. So it does
depend on the potency of the formula that you're using, but typically you're getting to a gram of day,
gram a day of the CBD oil or the THC oil slash rick Simpson oil. That can really wipe a person out.
I've had people put their whole dosage in a capsule and do it orally, and I've had people
put their whole dosage into a homemade coconut oil capsule that they freeze, and then they use
that coconut oil capsule from a little mold with coconut oil that they do as a suppository before
they go to bed. So there's there's multiple ways to get that in your body, but you do have to ramp up
on it. But don't think that, you know, be careful of websites that you have out there that say anything
is an end all be all for cancer. So you have to get this from a state that legally you could get this
from, and you can get it on order from multiple places if you search online. Okay, some questions.
I'm going to unmute everybody else. So please mute yourself if you know you have a lot of
background noise and that I get to open it up for questions. I've been taking this a share and I've
been taking a form of THC oil and I I'm approximately up to 15 milligrams a day and just at night,
and that just maxed me out like it makes me really rosy and like sometimes I can't even walk to
the bathroom I get busy. So I can't even imagine getting up to a gram and how much it would cost
because isn't one gram like a thousand milligrams? A one gram is a thousand milligrams. That's correct.
So I would question what the dosage is of yours if you're only at 15 milligrams of THC
and what the potency of yours is. So you probably have either much higher potency
or they're they're figured out they're a milligram dosage differently. But that being said,
I've had people take one the sixth on what a full dose is and they can't handle any more that they're
at their limit. So I would bet that your dosage is that your potency is real high. So you might
be getting an equivalent of maybe a hundred grams but you are still I mean that could wipe you out.
That's true. So that is bad. That is the real side effect of doing this is that many people
can't get up to those. And I've had people just stop and say forget it. I can't do this. I would
if this is good to be like pure I'm not going through it because I just can't handle it. It makes
it just wipes me out and I have that I have no life. So everybody reacts to these things differently. So
I've taken it but only taken it once which was a patient sample. I didn't notice anything.
But my body detoxifies. I think pretty quick too. So I think it just kind of went through me.
But everybody's going to everybody's going to tolerate this differently too. So it does depend on your
detox pathways. I don't I know that I've seen anything on what pathway that the cannabinoids detoxifies
through. So I'm not sure to look as far as your genetics to see where you where you could have issues
with detoxifying it but it is just like anything else. If you take something and you can't detoxify
it's going to stay in your system longer which is going to give you more benefit and it's going to save
you money because you need then you'll need to only take a smaller dose and get the same benefit
as somebody else who detoxifies it very well. It has to take a higher dose. So you really have to go
to tolerance. But I guess I'm concerned if I'm taking a fraction of what is recommended. Is it
really worth it? Is it because I was told if you don't do you know the right amount it's not going
to be you know there's no point in doing anything at all and I don't think that's true. I mean there's
certainly not any studies say that that's true. So and I think that part of your tolerance is your
ability to detoxify it or lack thereof. And if you're not detoxified it that it's staying in your
system longer therefore you're not tolerated very well. So you could do as well as someone else who's
taking three times as much as you and what dose that you're at. Any other questions? Dr. Connor,
a question about B12. I look through my supplements and it doesn't appear that I'm taking any
would it improve would it help me with my lethargy give me a little bit more energy to get through
the day. And then also what are the she-lators that you have? So yes so B12 if I have a lot of lethargy
a lot of fatigue a lot of tiredness could that be a deficiency of B12? Yes. This is crystal, right?
So we should probably look at your genetics again because you do want to look at those genetic pathways
with B12 as well. And if there's a need for them and then with B12 remember the type of B12
what to take is a hydroxycabalabine. It looks like this hydroxycabalabine and that's the
four of you what to take you know what to be taking a lot of methylcabalabine.
Like that. Okay so but we yeah and I also need to talk to you so you should actually call the
office it set up a time we should chat so. Okay I'll do that. Any other questions?
After Gunners this is step swords. I'm looking at the program sometimes I just go through the
live programs and some of these bacteria is I am like well like flukes for gallstones most of us
rules of cancer patients have gallstones. Do you include those in our rife program?
Not everybody. It's not in everybody's program. It's in a number of people's program but not in
everybody's program. How about the other it like um I have a desperate jealous. Is that in some
people's also? It's in some people's but not everybody. So I could look at yours and see if yours is
in there but I don't know that it is or not. Okay I was just wondering. I think you.
Okay I'm going to mute everybody good because there's something I wanted to share with you guys too.
So I do want to ask a favor of you. So one of the favor that I'd really like to ask of everybody
is if if you're willing we're not soliciting your input here but in a way I am
is to give us a review. So a review could be given over Google or could be given over Facebook
on a Facebook review or if you're having success or you're not having success and you're unhappy
with us we would like to know. So just email us maybe a little comment that we could publish that we
could look at. You could give us permission to publish it. What would be best if you would be
would be so inclined is to take out your video camera on your phone. So just take out your phone
and do a selfie video. Doesn't that to be more than a few minutes long but just say hey my name is
Bob Johnson and I just would like to give a little shout out to
Ricottor's clinic. This is what they did for me. This was my issue. This is what happened. This is
I'm still working on it on the work in progress or I'm having really good results or whatever it is
that would be really beneficial. So if you do that that would be I would appreciate it very much
and we would like to give you a little gift if you do that. So just not to pressure anybody
but if you feel so inclined that you've been blessed by what we do here we'd really appreciate that
because that really helps because the biggest one of the biggest things when people do call us they
want to know do you have any video testimonials or anything of anybody else that has done this program
and we don't because we just been really careful not to solicit that but if you don't ask you don't
receive so I'm going to put it out there and ask you guys if you guys are willing to do that so
all right I'm going to unmute you and we've got time for a couple more questions.
The one comment I have on that is if you get a lot more patients I mean is there a point where
you have to turn people away because you can only handle so many.
You know there is because we kid all they handle so many so we only do accept you know a few patients
a week so we're not at the point that we're turning people away for that reason. We do
turn people away that if I don't think I can help them or I don't think that they're a good fit.
So we do that quite often and if you you know have patients that you refer here currently we're
only accepting kids or patients so it's I understand maybe part of your thoughts are well I don't
want to give more much for patients I want or you know that he's not going to have time to keep
doing this stuff but we'll make sure that we manage that correctly.
Yes okay good question I'm going to mute everybody because we're getting a phone call coming in
there on somebody's line okay question do we have a clinic in Florida I made a comment about
two months ago that we're three months ago that we're hoping to open up a clinic in Florida with
Dr. Halterman. Well that didn't work out for multiple reasons and you know it's very difficult to
manage something from afar there's been multiple times in my career that I've had multiple clinics
and it does nothing but succ to live in daylightonomy so you talk about something that will drain
me and make me don't want to do this anymore it could be that but I thought with Dr. Halterman that
she would be able to manage it and everything would go well well it just isn't going to work out she
is moving to Florida and she has left her clinic already she left her clinic about a month ago
so she's no longer with us we parted in with you know good feelings I have nothing against her she
has nothing against me it's just that being a clinician and being able to manage a clinic is very
difficult and it's I cannot manage it from afar and I just didn't feel like that that was going to be
managed down there the way I'd wanted to be managed so it just we just can't do that the benefit that
we would have had had a having a clinic elsewhere would be simply that we'd be able to see more
people and to start more people but when that when ultimately the burden of seeing more people falls
back on me then I got to go okay well there's only so much of me and that's where you get back to
the previous question of well if you see so too many people is that going to you know be too much of
a burden on you in effect the way we read our clinic the answer is yes so if I was going to
if I ever did open up another clinic I would have to have such faith in another doctor
that that burden wouldn't fall back on me that that burden would be on another doctor
and I just that just hasn't been realized yet so the answer is log answer to a short question
no we are not going to have a Florida clinic at least not at this time if God changes the situation
at some point of time that would be wonderful but right off the burden all falls back on me it's just
just not possible and I one of the things I pride myself and I think I'm an optimistic person but
more than an optimistic person I'm a realist and I have to I could realize my limitations and see where
make you the decision could be here for all of our patients so we don't want them to happen
all right one last question anything uh yeah I had a question okay um this is
Patty Ross and um I had a question about when you you
uh there's some of the other um programs on the rife machine and say for example I was trying
to find something for the plantar fascia his on my foot and I really couldn't find that in the
programs but I used one for tendonitis and my question is is if I only I have the tube if the tube is the
only um uh the tesla tube is the only thing I have do I do I play that right on the foot or if I
was doing something for sinuses would you place that closer to your sinuses or your head area
does the the tube need to be closer to the area that you're trying to affect good question all right
I'm gonna mute everybody and I'll answer that so in when you're looking at other programs on the
rife to use there's not a program for every single thing right so let's say I have plantar fascia
I just said it's like oh I can't find a plantar fascia it is program but I found this tendonitis
program or I found this swelling program or I found this this accelerated healing program um would
that be a good one to use first of all the answer is we don't know just try it and I don't say that
facetiously I say that to help you understand frequencies just because even if there was a program
for plantar fasciitis does not mean it's gonna work for everybody's plantar fasciitis because
everybody's plantar fascia and healing the plantar fascia might take a different little bit different
frequencies so you might have to try some different programs so I always look for ones just like you
did patty that seemed to be similar in nature um what am I go twos and favorite ones is the accelerated
healing program it's in the normalizing frequencies folder so it's in the folder that says normalizing
frequencies and I think it's the first or second what it's called accelerated healing that one is
great for muscle aches and pains and damage and toward ligaments and different things like that
um and then the second part of the question is where do we place the bulb it's always best to place
the bulb as close to the area that you're trying to treat that's why it's like okay if I have prostate
cancer where should I place the bulb we'll put it next to you yeah it'd be good to hug it right down
by your prostate if I have breast cancer should I put the bulb right over my breasts well that would be
best as long as it's not shining in your eyes and keeping you awake so you have a balance there
but then if I run into a program during the day for a specific body part then yes you're better off
having the bulb close to that body part um it's uh uh somebody's chatting me here but it's um
it's you're gonna have better results the closer it is to that body part yeah if I had plantar fascia
program but I was holding the bulb in the head when I still have some benefit yes but you're gonna
have better benefit close to the body part second part of that question that you didn't really ask was
is the hammer tube the best bulb for everything well the answer is the hammer tube has enough output
that it can you could run any of the programs except the math programs with the hammer tube and you'll
be just fine um however if you're going to be concentrated on a specific thing then there are some
other bulbs that can be beneficial and you can look on rice website or you could contact us or
ask the question on facebook which would be a really good question for everybody to hear is where would
you use different bulbs and maybe I'll put together a little thing for you too uh there's what's called
the zinger bulb which is a real nice bulb for like a tissue massage and working muscles or working
to skin cancer or um some tissue area would be really good for plantar fasciitis uh there's a spiral
bulb which I guess I would know where I'd recommend the spot by the spiral bulb for except for
skating uh and then there's the double bubble bulb which there's um uh that can be beneficial for
certain things too but really the hammer bulb and maybe the zinger bulb would be two bulbs to have
with the foot bath uh somebody commented on the your issue with plantar fasciitis that they bought a pair
of vio vio lu c sandals and shoes and they made a world of difference i would also comment that i
started wearing flip flops last summer just some really nice Nike flip flops that seemed super
comfortable um but uh i had up with plantar fasciitis too and i had to go back to my berkin stocks
um and it took about five six weeks of back on to a good pair of berkin stocks to have finally my
plantar fasciitis completely disappeared and i didn't even run any rye programs for it i wear arch
supports in my dress shoes at work i've worn them forever and then i wear berkin stocks even in the winter
i have these berkin stock clogs that i wear um or i wear tennis shoes with a good arch but i don't
only use those if i'm going bicycling or working out or something like that all right so um
another question came in can you answer this next week for our time is the 23-B test that
say some of us used inferior to the one that you formulated oh good question is the 23-B test
inferior to the new test that we have making it so that it would be better to go ahead and do the
new test as well i would say no if you already did the 23-B test no you don't you don't have to with
the new update to the program and stuff don't we pull enough data out of there then i don't think it's
going to be an advantage to spend the money on doing the new test i don't think so so i think you're
you're just fine um and if uh you know even the version five test we got enough data out of there
i don't think we need to do the new test so no i think you're good all right i'm going to unmute you
and say audio to everybody and thank you for being on the call um i would appreciate a review
you'd more appreciate a phone selfie video um and um or something that would be great so thank you very
much for all you do for us and um please use your facebook the facebook uh uh channel um page to
ask other questions that you think would be beneficial to everybody and um we'll try to get answered
out to you as well thank you all right bye bye